what's up guys i'm david from gamespot
and if you're a battlefield fan like me
particularly a battlefield 3 fan you may
have heard about the new reality mod
made by venice unleashed now this build
is incredibly rough around the edges and
it's really punishing if you don't know
what you're doing but there's also
something kind of infectious especially
if you have a proper squad i'm gonna
break down what makes the gameplay just
so quote realistic in this mod and how
it all works drop that like button sub
to the channel especially if you're
excited for future call of duty or
battlefield updates and let's get
started this mod was countless years in
the making by some very passionate and
dedicated people and i've been deep in
the trenches trying to figure out how
this gameplay lube actually works
fans of classic battlefield call of duty
games check your expectations at the
door i'm serious you might feel more at
home here if you come from arma squad or
tarkov so let's talk gameplay you will
live or die by your squad's teamwork and
team composition i am not kidding if you
don't have a mic get one right now or be
prepared to be extra attentive to the
squad team and general chats you will
need to communicate or be listening at
all times for call outs since it's
honestly kind of hard to tell what is
going on by yourself unless you're
leading the vanguard there is an
incredibly minimalist hud that only
shows your stamina a compass how many
mags your gun has which again mags not
rounds and what the fire rate of your
weapon is set to your kit is completely
restricted to the role that you want and
there are plenty of different roles but
not a lot of weapons there are rules for
machine gunners though breachers light
anti-tank medics riflemen and more each
role has a set weapon with specific
attachments and minimal scopes no
one-man armies players are significantly
slower in the reality mod than in the
original battlefield 3. this is
deliberate to prevent excessive solo
flanks or lone wolf type gameplay you're
with your team for the long haul and
your roles are meant to support each
other one thing that stands out from the
roles is a section for a specific squad
leader the squad leader has certain
abilities that they can do like marking
objectives and giving out orders to
their squads while also establishing
fobs or fobs which are basically remote
spawn points to help ease the pain of
dying and responding since by default
you have to spawn all the way at the end
of the map at your team's starting point
it's a journey you can't spawn on your
squad mates if you die and you can't
spawn on captured objective points fobs
are clutch and once established loki
kinda need an extra eye on them since
they can be destroyed by the enemy team
if you need another point midway and the
fob's a little bit too far away from
where you'd like to spawn you can put a
rally point down if you have enough
squad members near you and you're not
being rushed by the enemy team now so
far there was only the aas game mode
which is short for advanced and secure
no team death match no conquest no
domination no any of those game modes
you are used to from the og games from
what i've played aas is basically the
core rules of conquest aka you can
capture and hold objectives and both
teams have a set of tickets that go down
with each successive kill however
the pacing completely different the map
sizes are similar to a classic conquest
map and yet there are hardly any
vehicles with a few exceptions maps like
the gulf of oman have helicopters and
boats with an aircraft carrier spawn for
the american team but beyond that
traversal is incredibly slow putting
more emphasis on your squad leader
establishing tactical fobs another
significant change is the way that you
communicate with your team battlefield
and cod have various text chats letting
you type to your squad or team or you
know let off some steam in the general
chat which is a nice way of saying talk
[ __ ] after you get killed but the
reality mod takes things a step further
in how it implements the voice chat
you've got three different keybinds for
voice chats each indicated with a
different color representing who can
hear you green is for your squad and
only your squad no matter the distance
yeah get over here on my way sir
squad members on the other side of the
map can still hear you when you hop into
this channel blue though is a new
proximity chat letting you speak to
anyone on your team even if they aren't
in your squad so long they're within a
certain distance
[Applause]
you got him
yeah good kill in my experience the prox
chat has a pretty good range and was the
one that i relied on the most definitely
put some headphones on and enjoy because
they're spatial audio too however it you
know took me a minute to get used to but
i will say this proc chat came in clutch
when i was trying to find a down
teammate or asking for help on revives
on several occasions
appreciate it
lastly you have a red chat which is the
hq chat now from what i could tell that
privilege is restricted to the squad
leaders letting them figure out top
level tactical strategies on which
objectives to hold which to advance on
what the priority should be for their
squads and even things like calling in
artillery make sure we set up some fobs
over
gotcha yeah we're on it now if you're a
generally casual fps player all of this
might seem a bit too extreme and it is
especially at first but the trick is you
just have to remove your shyness and
embrace the role playing a bit seriously
everyone is going for the same objective
and they all want to have a good time so
don't be afraid
down the road
what a cheater
bridge right reach right now i disliked
the mod the most whenever i was rolling
my eyes on my teammates yelling contact
northwest and mark h06 k4 but i'm gonna
be real they had the right idea cause
see while i was being cynical and
judging them for embracing the
role-playing too much you know what my
reward was yeah dying almost immediately
fast forward a few days later in my
playtime and now i'm out there yelling
into the prox mic that i'm a medic ready
to assist my teammate's size of relief
and constant things felt to be honest
really good
okay
trust me if you want to have fun in this
mod let loose embrace the roll the more
that you go full send into the team
effort the more rewarding the gameplay
experience a thing to be cautious of is
if getting kills is what brings you the
most joy in these shooter games you
might have to tweak your expectations
just a little bit getting kills in the
reality mod is not necessarily difficult
but it's not easy either and i'm gonna
be real i am not unfamiliar to the 10
kill plus streaks in games like cod or
destiny but in this reality mod there
were no markers to indicate enemies they
blend in with their environment and the
weapons are kind of really inaccurate
especially in full auto mode there is no
way to heal yourself if you get hurt
unless you are near a medic and if you
get shot the most that you can do is
stop the bleeding with some field
dressing now you can use a health back
to heal yourself if you are a medic
however i ran into instances where i
eventually couldn't heal anymore not
sure if that was a bug or if you
eventually just run out so keep that in
mind just the warning i don't think that
getting the most kills is what will lead
your team to success although i
definitely had some folks on my teams
that were just going balls to the wall
getting kills left and right and i
appreciate them however i'm gonna say
this a smart machine gunner laying down
suppressing fire might be the person
that saves your life from enemy fire
rather than the cracked out twitch
streamer that normally racks up 40 plus
elims a game in a regular cod match
therefore it kind of makes sense that
most of the joy i got from this mod did
not come from trying to get kills but
rather embracing different roles being a
medic in particular felt the most
substantial you will notice there are a
lot of friendly fire instances
medics are constantly in demand some of
my favorite moments involved me
sprinting through the fire finding cover
behind rubble or smoke where a down
teammate was and bringing them back into
the fight i didn't spend as much time in
some of these other roles but i
appreciated their benefits when my
teammates were stepping up to the plate
many under the hood changes to the
gameplay distinguish this reality mod
from its battlefield 3 counterparts if
you see a game mode in the servers that
say aas alternative it is the same map
except at night a neat twist showcasing
the reality mods dynamic day night
system although fair warning if you are
playing a night map prepare to shield
your eyes because the transition today
is uh
a little sudden
[Music]
i just got blinded
now the reality mod is available now and
it does require you to own a genuine
copy of battlefield 3 alongside all of
its expansions on origin or ea however i
believe steam owners can still
technically make the mod work you'd have
to look it up but i'm pretty sure you
can direct the game file path into the
origin client and you'll be good to go
when you connect the two accounts to the
venice unleashed account now listen i
said earlier that this mod is not for
everyone to be honest it wasn't even for
me in the beginning i went through a lot
of frustration trying to figure the game
mode out i was particularly agitated
when dealing with less cooperative squad
mates or running into the game several
bugs and glitches however once the bumpy
initial rounds were kind of in the rear
view mirror i started finding roles that
i could appreciate like the medic and i
ended up enjoying some really fun
moments if there are some neat gameplay
mechanics i forgot to mention that you
enjoyed in this mod please feel free hop
into the comments again this is a mode
for players ready to go all in the role
playing a little bit and you know maybe
you have some experience in games like
squad or tarkov which never hurts that
being said if you've never played these
games give this mod a shot and who knows
you might just enjoy it
[Music]
[Music]